nef aujourd'hui à tam tam fort mcmurray
en alberta l'acadienne d'origine
angelina gionet pas le sort des femmes
francophones hackers thème virale am la
danse kathak du nord de l'inde à saveur
montréalaise et torontoises sept enfants
une école de pâtisserie plus tard
l'histoire de mini sambou mais d'abord
le sud du canada est aux prises avec de
fortes inondations dans plusieurs de ces
régions qu'en est il de ces frais
couverts par votre assureur
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour ici raymond des marteaux
les crues printanières qui touche
plusieurs régions au québec mais aussi
en ontario ont été dévastatrices pour
déjà ils ont trait en fait d'importants
plein d'eau les logis maintenant il y en
a dans bonjour bonjour les airs bardos
vous êtes dans un de ces vous n'êtes pas
touché personnellement moi la touche
vous êtes vous prêt vous répéter je suis
touchée mais du sind aigle et parce que
mes enfants sont perdus
c'est la plus vieille trois jours
d'école parce qu'elle l'école et couvre
1 portion pas mal grandes écoles
secondaires qui touche l'île bizard puis
partie des sages un bief qui ont été pas
mal touché pierrefonds si on parle de
l'ouest de l'île au moment où vous vivez
la maison ça va oui mes frères soeurs
coulin mon frère qui habite à l'est le
blizzard puis j'ai un coussin qui avait
été sur le banc leur père font en fait
il prenait toujours des photos les
matins pour montrer au pilot y arriver
c'était pas mal a hot l'heure on voyait
plus les trottoirs c'était vraiment des
trottoirs à trottoirs les lignes de la
rue jean disparu sous l'eau pierre il y
avait beaucoup de d
des sentiments on ne sait pas quoi faire
parce que lui il a vite par exemple dans
une sous sol alors c'est compliqué c'est
simplement supprimées il ya par entrer
l'eau il a commencé à descendre puis ça
va bien maintenant
sauf que on attend des pluies ce
week-end il ya de la neige dans les
bassins versants dans non on parle du
témiscamingue du nord des laurentides
aussi et tout ça se déverse vers
l'outaouais double outaouais c'est vers
le lac des deux montagnes
c'est vers chez vous c'est ça et en fait
ces îles sont pas préoccupés par la
pluie défend semaine c'est plus le plus
tôt pour les choses qui se passent plus
loin parce que c'est ça il va il va
descendre par là pour les flames
puis c'est certainement une couche de
plus ado qui va voir ses jalons pour
bien des gens la résidence familiale ça
en fait souvent aussi cesser l'achat
d'une ville sera une perte totale il
faudra rebâtir pour da autres personnes
look s'est infiltrée au sol il ya des
dommages c'est peut-être un peu moins
important qu est ce qui est couvert
qu'est ce qu'il l'est pas par l'assureur
comment ce qu'on trouve des réponses
quand on vit fortes tensions aussi
essayer d'avoir assurez vous d'avoir
votre formulaire d'assurance bien près
d'où cette semaine marie jobin adjoint
marc levasseur levasseur et porte-parole
de kanetix une spéciale d'entreprise qui
est spécialisée dans l'offre d'assurance
différentes compagnies sur le web
elle verra pour demander d'y aller d'un
premier débroussaillage les frais de
subsistance et le bon exemple
mais certains contrats d'assurance vont
couvrir les frais de subsistance effets
profonds pour le savoir de toute façon
dès qu'une sinistre la première chose à
faire c'est de trouver son contrat
d'assurance et d'appui son assureur et
lui boggey qui est la marche à suivre
est de vous pouvez commencer il devant
les démarches pour savoir qu'est ce
qu'ils couvaient parce que ça vous
pouvez avoir pris séjour donne un autre
exemple vous pouvez avoir pris une une
assurance pour refoulements d'égouts
parisien alors si vous êtes juste en
marge de l'inondation bail est possible
que ce soit vous égouts qui refoule et
que leur ailier droit certaines
indemnisations c'est pour ça qu'il faut
comme je vous dis leur m
un râble téléphones à puce ont assuré
dès le début il va vous expliquer la
marche à suivre et puis évidemment
prendre des photos le sillon des gars
c'est une bonne idée de prendre des
photos des vidéos mais aussi de garder
les factures de toutes les dépenses
qu'on va courir justement pour la
subsistance ci est prévue au contraire
da litre indemnisés dans certains cas ue
d ordre d'évacuation dans l'autre ce
sont des avis d'éviction des conditions
souvent tu peux faire une différence
d'un ski sont couverts est-ce qu'il sera
pas oui par exemple si vous avez une
voiture qui est inondé
vous avez une voiture dans votre copine
inondations explique la voiture soit
couvert par votre assurance auto
si vous avez à contient évidemment
d'avoir l'avenant veulent mentalisme ce
qu'on appelle communément à tous les cas
ce que croit de voitures soient
couvertes
maintenant si vous avez pas d'avenant
inondations et bien c'est beaucoup plus
il fait vraiment du titre de dommages et
loyer parce que comme je vous disais il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ont ce traité
venant au bon moment fort parce que
c'est relativement nouveau au canada or
de moyenne au parc avec les contrats
léonins d'où vous d'origine argentine de
l'ouest de l'argentine ont pied la d2 la
cordillère des andes dans un coin chez
vous ce qu'on a connu des périodes comme
ça dans votre nom d'usager me rappelle
non
c'est mais plutôt en fait dans la
province de cordoba
je ne donne en mai l'espoir c'est que
c'est les petits villages qui n'était
fait à côtés d'arriver à bezons changé
le cours de la rue viennent pour pouvoir
bâtir le le quartier du pyla dans des
certains il ya eu beaucoup de pluie puis
la wii et à déborder la rivière mais
c'est pas comme comme sexistes
en contrepartie cette zone
elle est techniquement parlant très très
instable on connaît beaucoup de
tremblements terres de l'autre côté in
chile qu'en est-il de mendoça et le pire
tremblement de terre de l'argentine se
sont passées à même douce à mendoza
puissant coin qui sont près des courts
billets la dsds et la construction ce
différend aurait au reste du pays
parce qu'il faut qu'ils fassent les
maisons beaucoup plus résistant parce
que c'est une son sismiques inondations
et où tremblement terre quand l'étude de
l'assurance à ce qu'on parle d'assurance
ou chez en argentine mais c'est les
agences à l'argentine je me rappelais
pas mais je j'ai eu une fois en accident
un autre pied c'est difficile avec les
assurances ici je pense que c'est moins
compliqué mac os mais c'est surtout la
même chose il faut que ce soit écrit
peer tout tout tout ça sinon dans les
journaux tout récemment fait cette
semaine on pouvait lire quelqu'un d'un
est un des derniers pays du g8 où
commencent à offrir une couverture pour
les crues printanières pour les
tremblements de terre c'est connu le
conte vécu plusieurs canadiens
en fait les changements climatiques et
ils vont ils vont provoquer des dégâts
comme ça plus une des plus en plus
souvent
alors c'est sûr et certain qu'il va
falloir qu'il ya quelque chose qui
change parce que sinon ça va être
compliqué et marisa demande à marc
vasseur les raisons de la longue attente
canadienne kelly les serrures et là
dessus en fait c'est que il faut dire
présentation pro du gouvernement fédéral
pour essayer d'avoir ce qu'on appelle
une assurance national oin pour un
régime d'assurance nationale si vous
voulez pour couvrir justement ce genre
de séisme
évidemment le risque d essieux
si on regarde les chiffres chocs de
premier abord on voit que ya 30 ans par
exemple c'était les incendies qui était
la première cause du sinistre
c'est maintenant ce sont les inondations
et évidemment avec les changements
climatiques
il est possible que ça s'aggrave cette
situation nous que ce soit plus fréquent
alors ça va devenir vraiment quelque
chose qui va être un petit peu
incontournable alors lisez sur arbres
ils font comme je vous dis des
représentations faites gouvernement pour
tenter justement d'avoir une espèce de
programme qui va faire en sorte que ça
va vous coûter moins cher pour les
assurés de souscrire ces avenants la
balle est dans le camp de tout le monde
le chantier des représentations et qui
se font au moment où on se parle de
cette façon les autorités prennent
généralement des mesures on n'a qu'à
penser au programme gouvernement du
québec qui offre justement une aide aux
sinistrés qui ne soient pas couverts par
les assurances ne dit pas les chefs 150
mille dollars canadiens alors vous voyez
il ya beaucoup de choses c'est une
nouvelle réalité quelque part et pendant
ce temps aux états unis a beaucoup de
climato sceptiques qui sont au pouvoir
marc vasseur porte-parole de kanetix une
société spécialisée dans l'offre
d'assurance de différentes compagnies
sur le web
c'est un dossier signé maryse jobin
[Musique]
vous écoutez tu entends ma radio canada
international
léo qu'une belle histoire marie émilie
mini sambou ça vous dit quelque chose
manque pas d'énergie
tous les matins elle d'où elle donne des
cours de pâtissier à deux jeunes à
l'école qu'elle a fondée en 2014
le goût du palais chez mimi ballet faut
savoir une chose qu'ici à radio canada
international de leonardo aime beaucoup
la cuisine de léo moura chapman qui
fabrique un ex entre un brûlé et comme
il le dit lui comme elle le faisait mon
intérêt ces délais conduisent bah oui
c'est ça de la douceur
l activité essentielle ça mais par
contre la grèce un autre chose après
avoir donné ces cours me me reste dans
la cuisine pour préparer des gâteries
conduit commande qu'on arrive à la
maison une autre mission tout aussi
prenante aussi passionnante qui peut
vous surprendre quand elle occupe ce jeu
ce soir écouter bien sûr c'est palouma
qui nous raconte son histoire
je m'appelle marie midi mais on
m'appelle mon petit nom ces mini jeux
vient du sénégal et je suis arrivé ici
avec mes enfants et je suis une mère
monoparentale de cet enfant cet enfant
[Musique]
c'est ça c'est le petit point la commune
quand je le dis et vite loin de
s'emballer
[Musique]
ces quatre garçons et trois filles
mon garçon est né à 30 ans prend deux
ans maintenant
ma fille a 28 ans une autre personne qui
va bientôt faire polytechnique et la 21
ans et j'ai un garçon de 18 ans le mois
de mars parfait j'ai une fille de 17 ans
et j'ai une fille dès 14 ans et un petit
garçon mon dernier qui s'appelle jamie
qui a eu tant sont tous avec moi qui
sont à l'école puis d'autres suivront
bientôt aller à l'université et le
garçon qui vient de se marier
[Musique]
pour
avant de venir ici j'étais designer de
mode de montréal une petite école que se
formait des élèves pour la couture
mais quand marié décédé il fallait
changer de job là il se retournait faire
une formation ici à montréal et je suis
devenue maman pâtissière je suis j'ai
fait j'ai fait des cathos je fais de la
plongée riez qui fait très peur en même
temps et je viens d'où vraiment moi mon
école assure qu des neiges dites nous
quelles sont les principales
satisfactions que vous savez avec cette
école depuis que vous l'avez fondé le
plaisir que j'ai dans cette école c'est
de voir quelques unes
une personne qui rentre dans cette école
et qui ne sait même pas tenir une
douille doué bout de trois mois de
formation il arrive à vendre des
produits et aussi pouvoir aller vite
dans le marché du travail parce que la
façon d'enseigner
je me suis basée plus sur le côté
pratique 100% pratique je n'ai j'ai je
me soumets j'ai mes forces à vouloir
leur donner le maximum vraiment pour
pouvoir aller vite dans le marché du
travail
si on parlait des défis parce que ce qui
caractérise les mieux les entreprises
c'est vraiment les défis auxquels les
entrepreneurs sont confrontés à tous les
jours donc si on parlait de ce défi là
lesquels vous diriez qui sont les plus
importants le défi c'est surtout la
persévérance
quand on manque d'ambition quand on
manque de persévérance quand on manque
de patience
c'est très difficile il faut il faut
vraiment à cash comme on le dit attacher
la ceinture cette privé de beaucoup de
choses de se consacrer à travailler pour
pouvoir relever ce défi
c'est une fatigue souvent c'est le loyer
loyer coûte très cher mais avec la
persévérance est ce que tu crois surtout
il faut croire ce qu'on est
il faut croire d'où on vient et puis
mettre aussi nombre de valeurs mais bon
ça aide
ça aide et puis aussi voir des élèves
sortir avec quelque chose ça te pousse
encore à contigné et je sais que au bout
du bout du tunnel pour avoir une flamme
qui va s'allumer donc vous diriez calé
satisfaction en plus de poids que les
défis auxquels parfois housse est
confronté ce qui nous tient parce que
pour les débuts avoir cette enfant en
mono parentales et puis retourner à 45
ans pour reprendre des études pour
changer de métier c'est c'est ça qu'ils
m'ont ça qui me pousse à tenir les
élèves qui sont là et qui j'aime
transmettre mon savoir
je me suis dit que si parmi dix élèves
il ya une qui devient pâtissier c'est
comme si j'ai gagné
marie ml/min sambou une pâtissière au
grand coeur au micro de paloma martinez
[Musique]
m
dans le cadre du festival axé asie parce
qu'en fait on est en plein mois du
patrimoine asiatique au canada donc le
festival qui se déroule à montréal
lien week-end le plus loin le 26 au 28
mai on vous invite à venir célébrer les
danses indiennes le volet spectacle en
fait le contexte ça se nomme perles
d'ailleurs perle au pluriel
la danseuse américaine colline à chaque
petit et le jeune prodige montréalais et
je dis bien prodige car c'en est un
temps de vie rhallam tous deux vont
offrir ces perles d'ailleurs à la
découverte des danses de l'inde l'un
deux millénaires montréal dans tout ça
battant de vire est né à montréal
il vit aujourd'hui à toronto il poursuit
des études en danse au programme de
formation professionnelle de la school
of toronto dans ce film est bien revient
à montréal présenter un échantillon de
sa progression
je lui ai parlé cette semaine voici
quelques moments de notre entretien
[Musique]
quatrième le parcours est pris à
montréal je suis à montréal
la vie à montréal on trouve il faut
qu'on voulait que je fasse quelque chose
de culturel puis elle avait beaucoup
d'enfants qui campaient plus jeunes dont
justement cette affaire par capitaine
vienne et finit par beaucoup aimé ça
j'ai décidé de faire un come carrière
puis en même temps j'ai commencé à faire
la danse contemporaine je pouvais pas
faire du ballet et donc pour poursuivre
sa formation
j'ai déménagé à toronto pour étudier ou
ce qu'on dit sur les gardes puis nous
enseigne à d'entreprise particulièrement
le grand silence moderne est pas ma came
et barbu sur les contractions et gerald
est le plus important de la danse
contemporaine et moderne novembre
[Rires]
13e vient d'inaugurer les pros c'est le
diable qui vient de croiser leur honneur
la catin qui est très technique et très
forte et très décriée comme une lente
il ya beaucoup de pirouettes de
travailler qui on travaille beaucoup
avec les personnes qui jure estimant
qu'ils leur manquent il prend du coup
212 a peut être résisté à peu près
accessibles
ça peut être très sensuelle est vraiment
un style qui entre tout ce qui à
l'ensemencement vraiment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc le spectacle c'est lui moi je te
remonter deux pièces une pièce classique
trop classique basée sur le répertoire
du kathak donc ça reste une pièce sur un
site rythme et de la 406 senoble à damas
dont lg présentait plusieurs des
extraits du répertoire du kathak
pourtant difficile mon fric qu'on peut
faire avec
il ya des pièces qui sont en toute chose
plutôt est-ce qu'ils vont être plus
énergique et donc les gens sont montrés
tous les sens c'est le d'entre vous
rentrent dans la technique du qatar dans
la deuxième pièce qui se nomme éclosion
ça va être une pièce quand apparaît meka
taclant le siège de pouvoir montrer un
peu de mes créations de ce que j'aime
faire dans le quartier général à votre
porte aux jeunes mamans que j'aime me
joindre et dont son lapsus à la cerise
et ne pas avoir un thème précis et sa
perte en danse indienne classique le
gréement c'est un simulateur
sensibilisés par des sections et donc si
compter parmi nos enfants nous ce qu'on
fait c'est qu'ils rencontrent avec des
syllabes qui sont joués par les
percussions et 6 e pour raconter ça fait
que dix disques dare 1 go by ne plie pas
à qui on doit prouver face à frey 14 on
est très loin du capital
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors qui est la langue maternelle en
parler movistar le bengali et le
français et l'anglais donc en même temps
vire adam danseurs les spectacles dans
le cadre d'accès asie je vous souhaite
la meilleure chance du monde pour la
suite des choses que vous puissiez aller
en inde étudier cet été et surtout une
belle performance dans le cadre du
festival accès si tant de vire à la
merci beaucoup
comme on dit merci à 1,10 à vanier vad
oui merci beaucoup
[Musique]
vous écoutez radio canada international
internacional 2006 ya onze ans angelina
gionet s'installa faute maintenant et ça
c'est dans nord de l'alberta
son mari travaille là depuis quelque
temps sauf que elle elle était encore
chez elle au nouveau brunswick
originaire du nouveau-brunswick dans
l'ex du canada très engagé dans les
organismes d'être communauté madame je
n'ai est plus vraiment pour s'empêcher
une fois arrivé dans la capitale des
sables bitumineux du canada de
s'impliquer au sein de ce qu'on appelle
la kfa utb aux flots l'acfas et
l'association canadienne-française
régional de l'alberta elle va participer
à la mise en place de plusieurs nouveaux
services tant pour les francophones qui
vivent là que pour les migrants ceux qui
viennent mais aussi de plus en plus pour
les immigrés ceux qui décident de
s'installer à forte marge
maryse jobin s'est entretenu cette
semaine avec un jean un lyonnais
directrice générale régionale de l'acfa
red road of law aussi quelques moments
de cette conversation
mon mari travaille et ici ça fait six
ans que je travaille au nouveau
brunswick avec le sens national handicap
hier c'était de lamination entraide et
jeune maman monoparentale
je suis en 2006 le projet un serment
entre mon contrat à partir une clé ça
fait que j'ai décidé de l'avenir rejoint
normale ici en nahda
[Musique]
et
transpiré nagé en alberta comme j'avais
toujours travaillé beaucoup au niveau de
la communauté auprès des femmes des
enfants
ce n'était des chances de carrière je
m'en bas dans le privé je condamne et à
chaque fois qu'un travailleur
communautaire dont sociale pour tous au
travail et aller chercher des français
se mettaient à un choix de travailler en
privé que j'aurais préféré les sens
[Musique]
e
en charge est ouverte on cherche une
association francophone qui avait divisé
internet tout ça pour une techno y ont
trouvé rien et que j'arrive du décidé de
ne pas travailler tout naît d'un à
climatiser dimanche une après midi
quelques jours après que jeter l'eau
fille juive sont saines affiches qu'ils
aient association francophone de la
régionale goursaud noir qui rentrait
tout de suite me suis dit dans un chalet
chercher ma carte de monnaie puis quand
salissures c'est ma carte de membre qui
c'est lorsque j'ai appris qu'il y avait
un peu sauvage heures à la direction de
la séance en petite forme mongiat ticket
pour le poche
comme j'étais tellement charlie pige
tellement une gratitude pour le travail
qui avait été fait en francophonie avant
mon arrivée il ya d'un centre
communautaire de l'association
francophone y avait l'école francophone
il y avait un petit service des aides à
l'emploi aux francophones de trouver son
ou à des jambes en nouant tellement nous
entendons les singes et des stages sur
mon jeu me suis dit ban va construire là
dessus maintenant que j'ai regardé
alentours s'accroît des progrès qui
existe est qu'est ce qui n'existait pas
surtout suisse et l'autre j'ai réalisé
qu'il y avait trop de services à la
petite enfance
c'est tout ça qui va naître ni projet
que j'ai travaillé dessus j'ai commencé
par en 2007 puis en 2001 on rouvre est
la première gare de vie sont co phone à
forer parallèle à fond on avait beaucoup
de demandes à la clientèle francophone
de tous les niveaux en avait tellement
criant cabrette mais il y avait aussi
une grande majorité de sucre femmes
immigrantes pas me g immigrants qui
arrivait derrière je me sentais
tellement démunis
la batterie le directeur acer promet un
enfant lancé joël la gt j'aurai un monde
souvent justice performer en immigration
pitre et dans ses locaux qui tue vont à
siéger sur le comité provincial du rifaa
et tel rassemblement à l'immigration
francophone albert tcg siéger sur le
comité
jusqu'à ce que finalement on aurait eu
signal chaque enfant a besoin dans les
régions finalement ne lui un projet
pilote à cerner mairie pour mes nouveaux
arrivants francophones fait
qu'aujourd'hui alors moi je sens
maintenant ces projets le hyaric y est
encore puisant quatre employés plein
temps
[Musique]
dans un avenir proche il en veut prendre
ma retraite de ce que je fais ici c'est
certain vous pensez à votre action dit
autre chose à faire j'ai toujours écouté
mon quart qui j'ai ainsi qu'en septembre
où j'ai changé de carrière souvent dans
ma vie moi tout ce que gérante amis g7 à
100%
sinon j'ai donné ce que j'avais adonis
ifo je laisse la place à des plus jeunes
qui eux continuent à construire ou jus
[Musique]
alger minagi à la directrice de l'acfa
régionale 2 watts bof l'eau à la ville
dernier madame pioneer suit le prix
suzanne l'ami thibodeau qui décernait
une femme francophone en alberta qui se
dévouent pour l'avancement des femmes
francophones dans sept provinces des
prairies canadiennes
voilà c'est tout pour notre temps tam
d'aujourd'hui merci à vous d'avoir été
des nôtres merci à chantal st sauveur à
la régie est allé au gymnase images à
facebook live facebook environ
ici les mots de marteau à les revoir à
bientôt
[Musique]